and emotional literacy basically comes
down to better understanding what is the
actual emotion I'm feeling and is it the
right emotion or is it something else
welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host Hisham azuz and on this week's
episode I was joined by Chris Hatfield
the analogy of the news is our brains a
bit like a Google search engine anything
you type in it's going to come back of
evidence I loved this conversation
because it's about one of my favorite
topics mindset more specifically
developing a high performing mindset the
habit of self-reflection is really
important that's probably one of the
biggest causes I see of other things
like burnout imposter syndrome added
stress is people just not giving
themselves that time to reflect Chris
I've really admired from afar love is
content and I think the way that he
delivers practical insights to help all
of you better manage the trials and
tribulations of working in sales and
recruitment so in this episode we really
dig into how to bounce back from days
how to reframe limiting beliefs and just
really practical insights that hopefully
all of you can apply to your day-to-day
so you avoid things like burnout and you
have more good days than bad days enjoy
the episode
Chris welcome to the podcast thanks for
having me pleasure to be here thanks for
making the trip uh I've admired your
your work online I have a personal
interest in mindset trying to be the
best version of myself so always respect
someone who's on a journey to help
others be the best version of themselves
and a big part of the recipe is mindset
and uh being better equipped to deal
with life's adversities work adversities
uh through the mindset and the
principles and the Frameworks that
you're that you have at your disposable
so I'm really excited to really go into
the detail with you on mindset
performance because all you do all day
all week is help individuals with these
things yeah so I think I'm really
excited to dive into these things with
you so just to give everyone listening
a bit of immediate context around you
and the journey that you're on if they
haven't seen you on LinkedIn before or
connected with you if I'm missing
anything here help me out but from
everything that we went through together
you've been in sales for 15 plus years
you joined the sales World straight out
of University
um and a big part of your journey was uh
in your first sales position
door-to-door sales that was a a big part
of the general nice Catalyst where you
found yourself had to deal with anxiety
and found that particular part very
challenging 100 commission only and and
that anxiety had the potential to
you and that was a big part of
the the bigger part of the journey
um but yeah as we said sales for 15 plus
years but most importantly uh you
started your own business sales psyche
in September 2020 a covert business uh I
think there's a few of them around and
ultimately like what you shared with me
is you have free pillars in this
business right you have one-on-one
coaching you have morning mindset
sessions so webinar maybe one to many or
where people can access the information
and resources and things that you offer
and you can give that to more than just
one person sitting in front of you or if
that's on a video call and then the
other uh thing that you have is bespoke
programs and workshops that you
specifically design
um and build for companies that you
partner with and you're also in the
process of writing a book on high
performance mindset and mental health
within commercial roles
so that's what you've been up to since
2020 and then in between and up till
that you was in sales enablement roles
working in different
um businesses but ultimately you've
always been in and around the the sales
world yeah yeah spot on is that cool
okay summarize very well so so obviously
it's fair to say that you have and do
work with recruitment companies but a
lot of your work is in B2B sales the
whatever you want to call it go to
market teams however you want to call it
is that fair yeah yeah I think it's a
mix like when I talk about sales it's
everything from customer success to
recruitment to anyone that engages with
a customer really
um along the life cycle and the journey
okay perfect so I'd love to hear your
take then uh what we always like to
start with is
what do you believe are the common
characteristics and traits of current
top performers in today's market would
that be sales recruitment we can sort of
through it from a holistic standpoint
but what are those common traits and
characteristics that you see in people I
think someone first of all who's got a
strong level of self-awareness and I'm
bound to say that I think because that
sort of is the Baseline for everything
around mindset but someone who really
knows themselves and understands what
what's going on in their mind on a daily
basis and also isn't too hard on
themselves doesn't have this expectation
that they should always feel a certain
way but just being able to understand
when they are feeling a certain way how
they bring themselves back from it
um you know something I always say is I
got taught um boxing a couple of years
ago my coach said to me no matter how
hard you train you're still going to get
punched in the head and it was around
you know not trying to stop those
punches necessarily obviously you want
to reduce them but it's more about
knowing what to do when you get hit and
I think those top performers are people
who understand what to do when things
aren't going well and things don't go to
plan when maybe something goes wrong
when something happens outside your
control so I'd say that's the first
thing I think the second thing is
people's self-regulation is being able
to it's one thing being able to
understand your emotions it's another
thing being able to then decide what you
do with them and decide what they're
trying to tell you and maybe not trying
to tell you at the same time and then I
think the other biggest thing is your
self-talk is the conversation you have
of yourself I think you know in sales in
recruitment we talk a lot about how you
communicate with clients with prospects
with candidates around your product
around your service around what you do
but the biggest conversation you have
with with yourself and if that
conversation isn't an honest one isn't
one that you're aware of then those
other conversations aren't going to be
as powerful as they could be so I think
they're kind of some of the key pillars
really that I see in top performers
that's really interesting let's just go
I wanna I wanna dive straight in with
you but because you brought it brought
it up in there I'm super curious to hear
your take on how people listening to
this can develop self-awareness like I I
completely agree with you I've been on
my own Journey on that whether it be
journaling that's helped me whether it
be uh going on a journey of personal
development and that's helped me have a
different perspective and be willing to
look at myself in the mirror and go yeah
why do I feel these things why do I
think these things a lot of people don't
do that and a lot of people uh yeah
would rather just carry on maybe live
life on the surface level I'd rather
just not have to deal with what I'm
feeling these things I'd rather have to
you know brush it under the rug but
self-awareness is really important
and I listened to all the podcasts I
listened to it is a real common thing
but I'm I don't think anyone's quite
cracked because maybe there isn't a
golden bullet to it how you develop more
self-awareness like I don't know for
people listening that maybe struggle to
understand how they can be more
self-aware or they do want to become
more aware of who they are and how they
feel and why they feel those things
what's the typical starting point that
you have found yourself helping people
with what's that first step yeah I think
it's a great point it's a bit like
anything isn't it resilience confidence
you hear it banded around you need to be
confident you need to be resilient but
what does it actually mean and for me
one of the best ways to build
self-awareness is to build the habit of
self-reflection so you talked about
there around journaling which again I
think you know I Journal as well and I
think one of the reasons I do what I do
is I think you some people hear those
kind of words and go oh that sounds a
bit like hippie for me or a bit like you
know oh you've got to be you've got to
practice mindfulness and all this kind
of stuff which straight away people are
like well that's not for me I'm that's
not me kind of thing so I think the
habit of self-reflection is really
important that's probably one of the
biggest causes I see of of other things
like burnout imposter syndrome added
stress is people just not giving
themselves that time to reflect and
self-reflection it can be as simple as
and I will do this at the end of the day
I will record this on a Friday is a
weekly win so every Friday at the end of
the week I will give myself 10-15
minutes and I'll reflect on what did I
do well this week like what did I intend
to do and what when what happened not
necessarily what happened out of my
control but what did I do personally
from a business perspective and personal
perspective and I'll also do that on a
daily daily basis
um having set goals and markers at the
start of the day as well and just by
building that habit first of all I start
to notice okay what am I doing what's my
perspective on this when things are
going well am I giving myself enough
credit for it am I acknowledging that
and moving forward so I'm not saying I
might not be where I want to be yet but
I'm probably a lot further along than
where I was and what kind of
conversation am I am I having with
myself so often I'll ask myself how am I
better off compared to this time last
week or this time last month and that in
itself is a catalyst for that self-talk
as well and that conversation which
often as you said if people don't pay
attention to it is when that sort of
critical voice takes over that inner
critic and all you ever hear is you're
doing badly with this you're doing badly
with that and it doesn't matter what you
do you've spent 60 78 80 hours of time
at work that week in your perception you
think it's been a waste of time because
you haven't actually reflected on it
yeah the self reflection and building
that habit I like that that's that's
super practical and as you said if you
build that as a habit or at least
attempt to do make more space for that
it then opens up the doors to oh like
why am I feeling these things or at
least leading to asking those questions
whereas if you didn't intention make
space to go what one thing did I do well
this week what one thing did I learn
this week
uh yeah you might not never arrive at
just thinking oh like how did this week
go you just you just keep moving forward
to keep doing the day-to-day that that's
really interesting I think one thing
that that's worked for me which I think
is also in this which again could uh
hopefully make more people even uh
appeal to trying to make space to self
reflect uh in the week is just by not
going on your phone for the first hour
because what I've found is by not having
any external input I then reflect yeah
and that that's really helped me as well
like whenever I have felt anxious or my
uh voices in my head and different
things going on is very noisy if I don't
go on my phone and I go for a run or for
a walk I'm forced to think about these
things I'm forced to decompress and like
understand why am I so anxious about
this or why am I thinking about that so
much so I think that's another thing
that doesn't involve the word journaling
doesn't involve meditating whatever is
also just making that intentional space
for you to be with your thoughts which
actually for those of you listening if
you think about over the last week when
did you actually just have no external
input whether that's music podcasts
TV scrolling whatever it may be you
might be surprised that actually out of
the 24 hours a day there's typically
maybe always at some point
in external input that's helped me yeah
I think two things on that probably
about four nearly three or four years
ago now I stopped taking my phone to the
bedroom in the evening doesn't come in
there like you know I think it's I've
created that sort of space as this is
the place to go to sleep and I'll put my
phone in airplane mode for at least sort
of half an hour an hour before I go to
bed and I won't touch it for the first
hour when I get up because I think so
often I used to have that habit of it
would be there and if I couldn't get
sleep straight away I'd go and grab it
and scroll or you wake up in the night
and there's always a deal or something
or you waiting to hear back from someone
so that's one of the things you check
and then you've instantly woken yourself
up or in the morning it's the first
thing you grab before you maybe even say
hello to your partner or you know get up
and see some sunlight so that's been
really helpful as well of building that
kind of habit and increasing the
friction of of trying to remove that
from being something that we can just
sort of jump to really yeah really like
that so where I wanted to really jump
straight in is you are working with
individuals groups human beings on a
daily weekly basis to help them perform
better to help them fulfill their
potential work on their mindset and I
asked you in preparing for this what are
the three most common things that you
come up against so I just wanted to
start there and we can dissect each one
because if these are the most common
things that you see then there's a very
good chance people listening to this are
experiencing these things or have
experienced these things working for
them so the first one that you shared
with me is limiting beliefs so let's
start there like what what I'd love to
hear your take firstly is what what does
like when you say limiting beliefs and
you're working with people individuals
what does it actually sound like and
look like when someone has or is
struggling or is working through
limiting belief what does that sound
like what does that look like yeah it
could be a simple and some people might
be listening to this going straight away
yeah I know I've got enough people like
as you say what are they it could be
anything from I'm not gonna have a good
day today I'm not going to hit my target
or I always struggle speaking to these
types of sea level people or I'm never
going to be as good as this person in my
team or my colleague or I'm never going
to know enough and people sometimes will
ask you what's the reason behind that
and go I don't know it just is that's
just who I am it's just me you build an
identity around it that's a limiting
belief there's no real evidence so you
might go this one time this happened to
me and it's like how many times have you
done that 50 60 times but that one time
happened or didn't even happen to me it
happened to someone else you know and
you build those kind of limiting beliefs
based on other people's feedback and
experience as well so that in a nutshell
is what a limiting belief is
so you said there's no evidence so do
you is that a big part of it that
someone sits in front of you and goes
Chris
I just can't do this house I can't I'm
just not that good at it I've had a few
calls that have went okay but most of
the time it's yeah I've I've had to deal
with rejection I wasn't able to do that
objection uh that I got on the phone
so you said that word evidence there
which I find interesting so often are
you trying to help people understand
that you haven't really got any evidence
to back up
this limiting belief that you're telling
me that you have like what is it that
you find yourself doing to help these
people arrive at the destination where
they go oh like I've just decided that
I'm telling myself that rather than
going rather than actually
um under rather than seeing evidence
that backs up what I'm saying is that
what you find yourself doing or yeah
yeah and as a tool I mean the analogy of
the news is our brain's a bit like a
Google search engine anything you type
in it's going to come back of evidence
if you're saying in that scenario I'm
not good with sales it's going to go and
run through all the archives to give you
evidence as to why linked to
confirmation bias and back it up for you
and when we when we are often telling
ourselves limiting beliefs we're in a
very sort of statement mindset okay and
this is where our Primal brain is sort
of driving and our Primal brain doesn't
really know how to think logically it's
very driven on emotion so it won't
question things it'll just be like okay
if that's the case that's the case it's
very like the kind of chimp childlike
brain
and when we're like that we're not going
to challenge you so there's a tool
linked to something called cognitive
restructuring something called an ABC
method it's not always be closing
um but it's activating event beliefs
about the event and consequences and
this is used in cognitive behavioral
therapy as well I've worked with plenty
of people have said oh I've used this in
therapy I've never thought to use this
at work it's like well there you go like
these tools can translate but the the
idea behind it is you've got your
activating event maybe it's the certain
point of the month for the quarter or
you get an email from a candidate or a
court you come off a call and you think
oh no or you see a can we have a chat
from your manager for example and then
the activating event often we
internalize that which then creates
irrational beliefs about the event as in
I've done something wrong this isn't
going to go well I'm not going to hit my
target all those things and then we have
those irrational beliefs which then lead
to negative consequences which means we
lose focus on our role we change our
process that probably would have served
us very well if we kept going or we
think oh someone's annoyed with me so we
start pestering them or they're ignoring
me we start pestering them and now
they're annoying of you because you've
started pestering them so the idea
behind cognitive restructuring is to
externalize that activating event
through questions because when you ask
questions you activate the rational part
of your brain that's why for example
when we've all been there on a zoom call
when you're in a group and someone asks
a question you think what was that for
me like your brain wakes up from it so
it's asking questions which then can
create more rational beliefs and more
positive consequences so a really simple
example of this which I go through
people is go right okay let's identify
the situation you're in is there a
pattern because the more you can
recognize the pattern of it's oh it's
coming up at this certain point of the
quarter or whenever I have a call booked
in with this person this happens and
just by knowing that you can start to
preempt it or prevent it the second
thing is write down all your automatic
negative thoughts your ants like what
are the things you're thinking are going
to go wrong what are the things you're
thinking did go wrong and then imagining
your brain is like a courtroom you've
got the prosecution there throwing out
all these accusations saying this is
going to go badly this is terrible
they're not going to buy into you
whatever it might be you want to imagine
creating a defense and the defense goes
where is the evidence that this thought
is true and what else could be true here
it doesn't go don't think that we're
very big or sometimes people jump to
that don't they or you might say that to
other people or you shouldn't worry
about that or don't worry about that
doesn't work your brain will worry about
it more if you're saying that so where
is the evidence and what else could be
true in this situation and then also
what are the benefits of feeling like
this or thinking this how is this
serving you we're often very quick to
jump to here's all the negative things
but what's the benefits what's it
helping you preempt to prevent as a
result of it
interested so let's let's just make this
even more actionable I think that was a
really good breakdown but I want to make
sure anyone listening can apply some of
the things that you just shared because
that that sounds really valuable and
I'll be honest part of that made sense
to me part of it didn't yeah like when
you were talking through it so I was
trying to put my shoes then into
listening to that listen to what you had
to say I think it's really clear that
this is something that you do day in day
out right and I think you articulated it
really well but what I was thinking was
I might stop thinking okay that sounds
great but that sounds quite difficult to
go through that whole process on my own
like am I gonna need to work with a
therapist I'm going to need to work with
Chris so I guess would you mind sharing
using those principles that you just
said if I'm listening to write this list
right now I'm at my desk in the sales or
recruitment role and I'm listening to
this and I might have realized you know
what actually I don't know why I keep
saying I'm not good at cold calling and
I've I've recognized that there's a
limiting belief
what what would be the first step then
to use some of those principles that you
just said that I can do of myself that
should hopefully make people feel like
yeah I can do that as straightforward
and they can start helping them
understand some of the things that you
just said around how they can start
shift shifting their perspective of I'm
not good at making cold calls yeah okay
so that would be the first sort of pivot
point I mentioned around the trigger the
activating event is cold calling so
every time you think about cold calling
this thought comes up yeah then you want
to go through okay what are my automatic
negative thoughts like what's the reason
I don't think I'm good at cold calling
or what my worried is going to happen is
it how people are going to respond to me
is it because people are going to ask me
questions or people are going to judge
me and look down on me because I'm cold
calling or you know getting all those
things right down yeah write all those
things down is it I don't know how I'm
going to handle this or I'm worried that
other people were listening to me while
I'm cold calling I can't hear a lot as
well when no one really is yeah 100 of
them on that one
um so yeah get all those things down so
we might say let's common one everyone's
gonna listen to me and people are going
to judge me yeah around it and
particularly if I'm not doing as well as
then I'm going to feel that even more
okay where is the evidence of this
thought was true where's the proof that
people are listening to you and maybe
not just listening to you but judging
you
well there probably isn't and okay
you might go oh this one time this
person listened to me and they said this
okay was what they said helpful
yes okay great cool so we've established
an over evidence what else could be true
in this situation is what else could be
true is that these people might listen
to you but that could be a good thing
because if everyone is doing well around
you isn't that a valuable thing to get
insights from other people wouldn't you
rather get it from other people than
carry on doing something that wasn't
working yes okay what else might be true
is well no one's listening to you and no
one no one really and this is what's
happening to the rational part here yeah
yeah yeah because you're asking a
question which then you have to go into
a logical headspace to answer because
you have to think about it you can't
just throw us a statement and then where
might you end end up if you go for that
whole process where would you then be
like do you just arrive and go oh maybe
I was thinking about in the wrong way or
it just then helps you you said next
time preempt or do things to prevent you
from feeling those things about making
cold calls yeah I think so the final
question there is what are the benefits
so the benefits of thinking this is it's
probably making me you know come across
in the right way on calls because if I
think people are listening to may I want
to come across quite sharp and I want to
be prepared for it so you then come
rather than coming up this statement I
don't like cold calling because I'm
worried everyone's listening to me is
I'm I find people with they are going to
listen is valuable because they will
offer me good information or good
feedback from my cold calling so that's
the kind of then statement you start
replacing it with is this is a good
thing because if people are listening
even if they're not that most people
aren't but if they are I'm going to get
something from it if it's you know it
could be if we pick other ones like
um oh I'm not good with presenting or
public speaking or I'm not good with
speaking with certain types of decision
makers where's the evidence or what
automatic negative thoughts oh I had
this one call and what happens if they
ask me a question I don't know the
answer to what if they don't think I'm
credible enough for it what if I burn
this opportunity for the company I'm
working for okay where's the evidence
that's happened some people might go
well I've had this call once with this
person okay and how did how often have
you had that kind of call one or two
times how many calls have you made in
the last month well hundreds okay so if
you flip it the other way around and
you'd had
um you know if you'd had two good calls
and 98 bad calls would you think oh I'm
gonna focus on you you'd worry about the
bad cause so if it's that way around
it's fine then you go okay what else
could be true here what else could be
true is that I can't control people's
reactions I can only control how I
respond to people uh what else could be
true here is that those people were just
having a really terrible day and I just
happened to call them right what's gonna
be true the what's going on in the world
right now they've probably got 101
stresses and I was just maybe the straw
that broke the camel's back but it was
nothing to do with me what are the
benefits of thinking this well it means
that I'm not getting complacent I'm
going to keep thinking about it maybe I
need to be maybe I can be more direct
with these types of people next time so
either way you're going to come to a
conclusion that also dispels those
thoughts and just sitting on something
that the more you sit on it the bigger
the story becomes hey everyone a real
quick one from me this podcast would not
be possible without our amazing podcast
Partners Vin cherry and Source breaker
because you listen to this podcast
you're able to get your hands on
exclusive savings on both of these
award-winning products if you're a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out vincere who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with Source breaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
Source breaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products love
it I think that'd be so valuable so
thanks for breaking that down I think
that that makes it really applicable for
people who listen to this right now and
helps them go on that journey of
reframing some of the things that they
have limiting beliefs around
so let's we'll put a a tick box for
Livingston Police I thought that was
excellent so let's go imposter syndrome
that's the next one right yeah uh and
we're not necessarily doing these in
order but these are definitely the top
three that you shared with me so I guess
why don't we just start with why like
I've I struggle with this I did a post
about this this week uh and I've been
using a different framing of it that's
really helped me
but like why what's your belief on like
why this is so commonplace like how do
you talk about uh why imposter syndrome
is something that more people speak
about is something more people claim to
have and that they have to deal with
yeah why what's your perspective on why
this can be quite common
is that saying 70 of us will be infected
by but I think it's probably higher it's
just lack of awareness sometimes I think
it comes from I mean you'll post mention
it around growth is that you know if you
weren't feeling imposter syndrome
there's probably there's probably no
growing happening there's no stepping
outside of your familiars I don't call
it comfort zone I call it familiarism we
can come to that if you want
um but stepping outside of it and I
think that's what why people experience
this it's it's reframing I kind of
alluded to it yesterday in that post you
mentioned
um but it's reframing that imposter
syndrome and again similar to your
thoughts is looking at the benefits like
if you think back to every time your
imposter has showed up if you think back
to every challenge you've had to
overcome your imposter has been there
like you you feel sort of empowered
every every time you've overcome a
challenge in your life and that's come
from probably that imposter as well so I
think that's one of the reasons why and
there are four different types of
imposters that we can kind of experience
one of those because I've seen you do
um content on that I think that'd be
educational for people yeah so the first
one is the natural genius so this is I
need to get things right first time
around and if I don't it's not because
it's a new task or something difficult
it's because I'm not good enough so this
will often show up in you know avoiding
trying new things in and Outsider work
as well and these can be you could be a
different imposter at work as to your
personal life when I go through this and
you can be a mix
so yeah it'll be like I'll have to get
things right first time around and
you'll feel you know a bit embarrassed
telling people how long maybe it's
turned taking you to learn something
you've then got the expert which is I
need to know all the answers I never
know enough
and I constantly constantly even
everyone else is telling you you're the
go-to person your biggest fear is
someone's going to ask you a question
one day and you don't know the answer to
it and you think oh that's immense shame
on you so it's and there's nothing wrong
of course with that kind of learning
mindset and all the things I go here
there's nothing wrong with the behavior
but it's the intention behind it if it's
being driven by fear it's not a healthy
and sustainable thing the third one is
the workaholic so this is where you
believe I'm never going to be as
talented or as knowledgeable as anyone
else around me so I'm always gonna have
to work two or three times harder first
one in last one out probably quite
anxious when I'm not working because I
see my whole identity as work as well
and then the fourth one is the most
common one which is the perfectionist so
you know I don't need to go into too
much detail about that but you can be a
mix of them and what I often encourage
people to do is the first step is
identify that mix and name your imposter
like give it a name
Christian okay yeah what what's the
purpose of that so if you imagine
um you know if you're thinking about
going on holiday with some friends and
you're like right where should we go and
you've got like two or three friends one
of them is like oh we should go to
Mexico we should go and do an
all-inclusive we're like oh we go to
Costa Rica we'll do an adventure thing
you know the clear difference between
your friend's opinion and yours you're
like okay that's their opinion and this
is mine
it's the same with your imposter by
giving it a name you can start to
identify this is my imposter's opinions
this is his thoughts or her thoughts on
this situation it's still valuable I'm
not going to try and ignore them but
they're not mine and it's just being
able to break up that identity and avoid
it sort of coming under all one roof
which sometimes you know when people are
in a situation and you go maybe you're
in a situation your life about wanting
to move home or like what you do at work
and you've asked 10 or 12 people you you
then start to forget like whose opinion
is whose and you're like am I doing this
for me or am I doing it for other people
that's like an example of often what
happens when we don't name our imposter
yeah I like that that's that's useful
let's let's talk about reframing them
because I think whenever I've tried to
learn about imposter syndrome and
dealing with self-doubt and yeah dealing
with those feelings and
um trying to do everything I can to make
sure that I don't become crippled by
those and and that that voice is really
really loud like that imposter's voice
is is really loud uh what what I've
understood what's helped is it's normal
like normalizing it and understanding
that yeah if you are pushing forward
getting out of your familiar Zone as you
said that that is part of the process of
course you're going to feel like an
imposter if you are going into new
territory and you are growing as a
person and I think as I said in in the
post that I did what's really helped me
is understanding and knowing that
because you are you know growing moving
forward don't have all the answers
you're not meant to have all the answers
that that's part of the the journey and
I think the key to it
um which has really resonated with me is
yeah not uh presuming you know more than
you do and that really helped me because
I'm I'm someone that
um yeah is willing to be humble and have
the humility so not going into every
conversation and going into business and
trying to grow my business feeling like
I know all the answers that's absolutely
tiring to you know feel like yeah I'm
making all the right decisions I know
what I'm doing rather than okay I may
not know everything about this just yet
what do I know and what do I have to
learn and and be and accepting that so
what what have you sort of what
reframings and framings have you found
helpful for people when you've uncovered
the yeah they've been listening to their
imposter too much or that imposter voice
and opinion is really loud at the moment
what sort of things have you found
helpful for people to reframe that yeah
I think first of all to your point I
think what it also does to you to what
you were saying it builds relatability
it builds connection with people builds
relationships is you know we've all we
all have those perceptions of people in
our Lives who we think oh God they're
you know they're so good at this they're
so good at that we find it very hard to
relate to them but you know that's why
you'll listen to someone on a podcast
you'll hear someone else's story and you
go oh my God I can connect with that
because they've been vulnerable they've
been open about something I feel like I
can understand that person more now and
I think that's where like you know you
look at social media you look at sort of
influences and content that's where
people are gravitating towards more now
is they want the very real person behind
it
one of the things I shared this on your
post I heard years ago was you know I'm
here to learn something not to prove
something I love that so much and just
going into that mindset even if you're
you know going in on a call with uh a
company or a candidate is I'm here to
learn something about them I'm here to
learn something about how I conduct
myself I'm here to learn something about
anything each day and coming in with
that mindset takes that pressure off
around it as well
the reframe that I often use which I
referenced in the post as well is
um imagining your imposter like the role
of a villain in a film so if you look at
any good story arc and there's a really
good book story brand that talks about
this I can never watch a film again
properly without thinking about this art
but you'll you'll come in the hero will
sort of you know be quite plateauing
sort of going along flat the villain
will come in and the hero will challenge
them and they'll fail and then they'll
go for a little Montage of change and
development like Batman goes into the
cave and comes back out the pit comes
back out and fights Bane and is
successful now if you don't have that
villain in that film first of all it's
not a very good story no one watches it
secondly the hero doesn't change the
hero stays the same and you are the hero
of your story and that villain that
imposter he's not saying it is a villain
it's the role of a villain is to come in
and cause that change and cause that
development and cause that growth to go
right what do I need to level up from
now and when I do get comfortable with
an environment when I do get familiar
with it then it will come back again and
that's okay as well but it's on what you
can control in the situation so another
tool I use around this is when I'm
working with people is dealing with
those kind of negative what-ifs is what
you're imposter will often throw up like
what if this happens then this will
happen then this will happen what if I
get asked this question on this call or
what if this person says this to me and
then this and then this and you build a
store in your head when the first page
hasn't even been written yet so the idea
behind it is going okay what are the one
or two biggest reasons I think that
might happen well one or two of the
biggest reasons I think this person
um why I'm feeling like this why I think
this objection or this question will
come up why I don't think this call will
go well okay it might be they're going
to ask me a question I don't know
they're going to throw out an objection
the person on the call I haven't met yet
okay what are one or two things I can do
to reduce the chance of this happening
prepare for that question preempt that
objection on the call research that
person on LinkedIn beforehand speak to
the decision maker I would have contact
with and ask him a bit more about what
does this person want to hear what kind
of information do they appreciate okay
and by doing that I've turned it from
like feeling and this thought into an
actual action and the key thing here is
to then go into that call and not at the
end of it and feel relief or that
presentation not feel it what we do is
we feel relief thank God that didn't
happen oh God I'm so glad I got through
that you know and you just park it but
that's the point to go well hang on did
any of that happen and if it did without
those feelings and those thoughts I
wouldn't have probably done that I
wouldn't have prepared in that way I
wouldn't have preempted that objection I
wouldn't have researched that person so
what you then start to do is build a
level of gratitude towards those
thoughts and those feelings which can
then build a healthier relationship with
that imposter because then when it pops
up it's almost going oh why are you here
too okay what are you trying to tell me
like you know what's the signal here I
like that it like encourages to do that
extra prep which meant that call went
well yeah there's a better way to it's
he yeah I really like that and what I
also loved about that example is
like those feelings and that overwhelm
uh of that imposter can make you feel
like you're not in control of it but the
way that you just talk through that the
what ifs and then okay well what can you
do to help you know um make that less
scary or these there or like be best
prepared you then turn everything back
into your control and that that's really
empowering
okay next next one then I'm gonna join
this the next one is
like you you showed me relationship with
their emotions but you like to use the
word emotion emotional literacy talk to
them about that what does that what do
you mean by that and why is this
something that you see in the law or
what does that look and feel like yeah I
think emotions is is one of the the
biggest pillars in which we
misunderstand and and we feel have a
much bigger hold over us and emotional
literacy basically comes down to better
understanding what is what is the actual
emotion I'm feeling and is it the is it
the right emotion or is it something
else and also understanding what it is
or isn't telling me to do or how can I
respond from it
um a study
um this year I think Deloitte published
it where they were saying that you know
there's 25 kind of core emotions that we
have words for but there's 34 000
combinations and straight away there's a
you know there's a whole sort of I mean
I ask people often like what do you see
is that as the problems with that and
and one of them is mislabeling it is
that you can often mislabel emotions you
could think oh this is anxious this is
anxiety this is stress and because it's
a habit you think oh it must be this but
it's like then as soon as you start
saying that that self-talk that limiting
belief it's like coming in here and
going there's a fire we need to get out
like I'm anxious like straight away it
puts your body into that fight flight
freeze or Thorn state
so that's one of the things that can
happen or we can assume the opposite we
can maybe wake up one day and think oh I
don't feel motivate today I don't feel
excited oh I must be unmotivated but I
don't feel really positive today I must
be unhappy we often go to the opposite
end of the scale sometimes when there's
of course a lot of gray in between the
black and white as well and emotional
literacy is being able to understand
that and properly label it and work
through it as well and also the key
thing here is seeing emotions as signals
not threats so similar to the example I
mentioned before it's almost like
Imagining the smoke alarms going off in
the house rather than the house being on
fire but often we'll start to think I'm
starting to feel stressed so we it's as
if the house is on fire already we're
going no no it's trying to tell you
something it's a bit like when you're
thirsty you know when you think about
when you're thirsty you don't go what
would happen if I didn't drink for a
week or two you grab some water and
you're like oh great you don't wake up
going I hope I don't get thirsty today
you see it as a key sort of you know
thanks very much for keeping me
dehydrated so it's almost like getting
to that point with all our emotions is
that when stress or rings anxiety starts
to come up it's not saying I'm stressed
or I'm anxious is I'm starting to feel
stressed or anxious for example and
here's what I'm gonna do to counteract
it from it and and here's what I can
then decide how I respond to it I don't
always need to feel something and act on
that feeling it's it's a signal it's not
a commandment it's a feedback loop
yeah I really like that the the thing
that's going through my head right now
though
is
I really like the way you're talking
about it but I do feel like you may
disagree but I do feel like that's very
reliant on the person being quite
developed to being able to take step
take a step back and I know like you're
not saying that you're gonna be able to
do that every single time like we're not
perfect and it's hard but what
you're saying is if you can have the
ability to see your emotions and signals
not as you said the house being on fire
so not instantly jump into I'm anxious
I'm these things rather saying oh I'm
starting to I really like that that's
really helpful
but I feel like that that is going to
take yeah someone yeah quite well
developed to when everything is feeling
like on top of them shit's going wrong
they're also going to feel like things
aren't in their control
to go oh yeah this is this is just a
signal like I'm not feeling these things
I feel like that would take a lot to
take a step back in those moments I
don't know if you found yourself trying
to help people wrestle with that but I
can imagine for some people they're like
there's just no way I could I don't see
how I could be able to take a step back
I don't yeah I don't know how we feel
about that but that sort of was going
from my head when you're just going
through that yeah yeah so coming back to
limiting beliefs is almost changing that
to a question of going rather than
thinking I don't see how I could do that
is what could I do to get to that point
like you know what one or two things I
could do and one of them is first of all
you know often it's in that situation
when you're feeling a very sort of
stressed or anxious it's often you've
you've kind of not really noticed it
before it's happened and that's comes
back to that self-awareness pieces
noticing more of your triggers so like
notice what you notice it's the sort of
three steps to like notice it name it
neutralize it so
um noticing what are some of your
triggers is one of the steps I'd say if
you if you're not at that point which
I'm not saying everyone should be just
by me talking about it today but one of
the things is okay start to notice like
what are some of the signals of you
being stressed or anxious and not like
what you're thinking but what you're
feeling for me it's like a tight chest
or I start tapping my foot or like a
clench in my fist so when these things
come up now I'm like oh I'm starting to
feel anxious like before I am actually
anxious so that's a good thing to try
the second thing is something linked to
something called the 90-second emotional
window so this is often what we can
struggle with is something will happen
that's what cool it's not the actual
thing that's caused us to sort of
exacerbate the situation it's our
response from it so you might have just
got off a call and instantly you go I'm
gonna have a terrible day today or you
get that email first thing in the
morning you go off like you know pushed
it back to next month or whatever it
might be or you get that slack or that
message and you snap back at someone or
in your personal life as well like
what's happened you're in a bad mood
a 90 second window is all about Studies
have shown that within 90 seconds our
bodies can reset themselves back to a
natural state
it's often our minds that Keepers living
longer in that so the idea behind this
is giving yourself 90 seconds in moments
and then one way to do this is getting a
stopwatch out on your phone or your
Smartwatch putting 90 on and counting to
it so it's building that habit and even
I've had people who put it on like a
Post-It note on their desk people who
want to work on this
um 90 seconds and you'll you'll count to
90 maybe remove yourself from your desk
go outside get some fresh air if you can
if not you can still do it there and
count to 19 because you're counting
you're having to use the rational part
of your brain which interrupts the
Primal part which stops all that kind of
ego and stories coming up and because
you're counting you're having to be
present as well and then it's deciding
what you do after that so you might use
that 90 second window and then go okay
am I am I really stressed what else
could be like the same question I used
before what else could be true here what
other emotion could be true here am I
hungry am I thirsty am I tired you know
before I jump to that conclusion um
yeah that that's interesting so just so
I understand that you're saying within
90 seconds you can change your state so
if uh I had a deal drop out
you're saying get your stopwatch out
count to 90 seconds
and that's a time where you're filling
these things maybe counting so you're
jumping into your rational part of your
brain as you said and then what after
that you're then changing your state or
those 90 seconds just to fill those
things and be in that gives you that
window to feel it and then change it
just understand that because I I yeah
yeah let me understand that yeah so at
the end it's going do you know it's just
being able to put yourself into a
rational state so that you can then make
a logical decision at the end of 90
seconds right rather than jump straight
to I'm gonna have the worst day
ever today yeah because your Primal
brain is driving you're you know your
your receptors have gone off you're in
that fight flight freezer phone
the 90 seconds is hang on let's step
back right okay I'm now rational let's
think about this kind of thing so it
puts you into that state you might still
want to respond to that person
afterwards you might still say something
to yourself
but it's in a more intentional manner
rather than a reactive manner you're
responding rather than reacting from it
yeah because that was going to be one of
my things around giving advice for
people managing the highs and lows and I
think that's the thing isn't it yeah
because I think that those people that
don't let
uh those moments dictate how much longer
they sit in their mind and it you know
those moments affect weeks not minutes
um
it's often the the mixture of top
performers too average and and
underperformers yeah yeah it's having
those moments you know why should I have
to wait for tomorrow or next week to
start again like why can't I just reset
myself now and again it comes down to
the more people disempower themselves
the more they focus on the
uncontrollables the more helpless they
feel around it the more you can bring
your rational brain in the more you can
Empower yourself the more you can
recognize you can reset that and I've
got a really nice proverb that I heard a
Chinese farmer proverb that I can share
around this as well that
um the kind of line I say to myself now
is I don't know what this is yet I can't
call it
I like that
so as you come to the end here I'm
really glad that we broke those down
because I think there's so many
practical things that people can use
day to day with what everything you
share today and those are some of the
most common things that you find you're
helping people with so couple just
couple final notes before you finish
them
one of the things I saw in your office
you've got rest as hard as you work
I want you to talk to me a bit about
that because clearly you're that means
something to you because you've got it
on some sort of like plaque or it's a
piece of artwork and the context that I
just want your thoughts on
is and this is what I maybe wanted to to
end on
is like I I really I really like that
and that resonates with me I I'm a good
sleeper I I rest I don't know
it's important
but I think you're a bit older than me
because I saw it on one of your posts
like mid-30s right yeah and it'd be
interesting to get your thoughts like
the leaders that I speak to
a common thing that I think we don't
want to paint everyone with the same
brush here right but I do think there's
an element of work-life balance has
potentially gone into too much in One
Direction this is this is my thoughts
I'm 30 years old and I feel like when I
speak to other people that are managing
typically younger people uh a lot of
people want all of the success they won
Chris's lifestyle that he has he's a
successful entrepreneur all these things
but I also want to uh show up at work
9am Bangla dot leave 5 P.M every single
day and then and these things and I'm
not saying don't work smart and you have
to always work long hours in these
things but what I'm often hearing is
people want everything people expect to
begin everything people yeah want the
lifestyle that they see but then in the
same breath
want the work-life balance and I don't
know what your views are on this but I
think it's very easy to share the
importance of resting and of course
that's important and work-life
balance but oftentimes uh you can see
these people online who are sharing
these things that do have their life
made out or they've been successful or
these things if you were to say okay
well what sort of work-life balance do
you have in your mid-20s well actually
you didn't have a partner I
didn't see my kids do you know what I
mean so I don't know what you think
about this but uh I agree rest is
important but then I don't know
if you feel is an element of it's gone I
don't know yeah they're my thoughts I
don't know I don't know what you think
yeah and thanks for sharing that I
totally agree with that just to give
some context that art is from uh notice
notes to strangers it's a guy called
Andy leak on Instagram went to a New
Year's party this year gave it some
artwork
um to put up around London on none on
properties we wouldn't get in trouble
for by the way just to reference so if
you if you live around London you might
have seen some of the stuff I stuck up
but I kept one of those because
obviously I do stuff a lot online but
the idea behind that I think it's even
in the words and what resonated with me
there is rest is as hard not as much
like as as much because hard is we
perceive hard as time still but it's
it's it's balanced and it's not saying
you have to have an equal amount of time
of rest to work it's but what you do
within that time that matters as well so
it is because you hear the one like the
classic one is you know work hard play
harder that kind of thing but that
doesn't take into account the kind of
rest and and rest isn't just sitting
there doing nothing rest can also be
what we talked about daylight reflection
awareness like getting to know yourself
more and and and working out how you can
then work more efficiently as well from
it but but I agree to your point I think
there is this perception now of you know
seeing things online and thinking oh God
like you know I want that and that seems
so easy like for our working week and
all this stuff
um and having that perception but it
isn't you know it's not matching their
goals and if I whenever I work with
people if I don't think that it's
aligned I will be honest with them and
say you know if you want if you want
this but you're only putting this you're
not you're not going to get there
um but again it it comes down to what
you can and can't control and whether
it's a manager listening to this or a
company you can only set the scene and
you know those kind of people that you
want to attract that do want to put that
energy in but also it's not thinking
they have to and just holding everyone
to the same account thinking everyone
has to put x amount of energy into the
same amount as I do
um you know it's having that that line
and understanding that people work in
different ways but it's just when people
are their their input sorry their input
is a matching they're expected out yeah
that's the thing yeah it's that and I
find that super interesting because I
almost feel like things come they'll
come in Full Circle and different things
a lot I've written about this a lot just
because from my conversations I almost
feel like
you used to hear be successful in the
sales be the first one then last one out
that's almost become no one does that
anymore oh certainly less people do that
so if you actually have a really good
work ethic you've got a
competitive Advantage now whereas maybe
five ten years ago that was just
standard like that's what everyone would
be doing don't think there's many people
doing that right now so actually having
a really solid work ethic has become a
competitive Advantage picking up the
phone that's become a competitive
Advantage because it's become really
familiar to
email these things so again that's come
full circle and then you can bring it to
things just because of the things that I
listen to stuff like almost I'm really
lucky that I'm with someone that want to
build a family with and these things
maybe you can talk to a bit more I don't
know your uh relationship uh status but
I'm also hearing everywhere I listen to
how dating apps and all these things are
failing and uh one of the ways that we
could help that is face-to-face speed
dating events
yeah so find these things come like full
circle and I just I do just find that
fascinating and for someone that is
always talking to people about mindset
well-being performance I do wonder
sometimes that all of the positives of
people speaking more and and these
settings I guess it's just a natural
effect that that also can have a
negative impact in terms of people very
quick to go
yeah I'm I'm burnt out and it's like
well what do you mean that you're about
I don't know I just feel like has it
almost sometimes it could be has it
become very easy because it's so talked
about now to point at someone go yeah
I'm not oh I feel that I don't know it's
I'll find it yeah well I think it that
comes down to a lack of education and
it's down to you know it's
responsibility of leaders and companies
you know going back to what you said
first one and last one out that just
used to be thrown at people but you
didn't tell people what to do in between
so of course people think well hang on
what am I doing then you've got everyone
just sitting around or just you know
spacing things out or that kind of
Parkinson's law the longer you give
yourself to do something the longer
you'll take to do it so I think it needs
to come down to education as well if
people are saying oh I'm burnt out is
you know have they been educated on what
burnout is are you providing a platform
for people to understand this
proactively within the business or are
you just waiting to address it
reactively because yeah a lot of the
time it might not be burnout and that's
one of the things I talk a lot about is
the difference between are you stressed
are you burnt out but if you people
don't know people might assume that's
the case and of course sometimes it
might be that people are trying to use
it as an excuse but that's down to you
as a lead of hiring poor people like if
you are going to give people a space and
environment and give them you know
encouragement and education on this if
people are going to take advantage of it
that's that's down to you for the wrong
kind of people and the people that won't
I will value that and will appreciate it
as well and this is what I talk a lot
about
um accountability and vulnerability it's
just because you allow people to more
vulnerable it doesn't make them less
accountable you can still have both it's
not saying you allow people to turn up
every day and not be their top performer
and not be their Peak Performance but
what you are saying is on the days where
they don't feel like they can be it's
okay to talk about it and they'll have
the support and anyone who takes
advantage of that that's your problem
for bringing those people into the
business it doesn't mean you shouldn't
do it for everyone else that is going to
see that as valuable and give as much
back then yeah well Chris how can people
connect with you work with you yeah so
um connect to me Chris Hatfield on
LinkedIn if you type my name in Google
Chris Hadfield the famous astronaut will
come up I get tagged in that probably
once or twice a week still Canadian
astronaut he's on the Canadian bill as
well
um so yeah Chris Hatfield and the
website is sales psyche which is psyche
dot Co dot UK love it well I really
enjoyed that conversation keep doing
what you're doing like as I said when we
first connected outside looking in uh
really enjoyed the uh just yeah seeing
the journey that you're going on always
respect people who are yeah building a
business which is centered around
helping other people and and helping
people be the best versions of
themselves which really resonates with
me so kudos to you and absolutely love
the chat yeah thanks for having me thank
you so much for listening to the episode
I hope you enjoyed it and got value from
the conversation if you did enjoy it
please don't forget to like share and
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
episode